kate la sphère patrick dils alors que la
cour de cassation doit se prononcer
mercredi sur une éventuelle révision de
son procès à cause de la présence de
francis heaulme le tueur en série sur
les lieux du crime
de nouveaux témoignages semblent mettre
le mettre hors de cause patrick dils a
été condamné à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité pour le meurtre de deux
enfants près de metz en septembre 86 il
avait alors 16 ans et selon certains
témoins dont un officier de police à la
retraite
des témoignages à décharge n'aurait pas
été pris en compte à l'époque valéry
ermite estelle matthew à fr3 l'anssi
patrick dils a aujourd'hui 30 ans il
n'avait que 16 ans lorsqu'il fut arrêté
pour le meurtre de deux enfants
après ses premiers aveux patrick dils
n'a cessé de clamer son innocence
voici son dernier témoignage les
pressions mentales au maire ce trajet
est un ancien policier en 87 il assisté
à la reconstitution des deux meurtres
treize ans plus tard il décide de parler
rapporté ce qu'un autre policier présent
à la fois sur les lieux du crime et
pendant la reconstitution disais ce jour
là le brigadier s'assure j'ai
constamment et se révoltent et même
contre le fait que l'on ne patrick dils
en quelque sorte finissait par faire
tout et n'importe quoi et nous tendons
s'insurger de voir que les petites
poupées qui représentait à l'époque les
victimes
qu'il a été chargé de remettre en place
ce n'était pas comme ça au maire
stragier n'a pas oublié non plus le
témoignage d'une de ces vieilles dames
qui apercevant patrick dils pendant la
reconstitution lui a fait part de son
étonnement quant à la physionomie du
meurtrier
elle me dit tout de go à leur monsieur c
dont paul vieux monsieur connor buvait
que sa bicyclette
or patrick dils n'avait que 16 ans et
pas de bicyclette
francis heaulme tueur en série notoire
était lui à vélo le jour du crime
ils n'avaient certes que 27 ans mais son
visage n'était pas celui d'un jeune
homme
marguerite posocco a elle aussi décidé
de sortir de son mutisme
elle dit avoir aperçu patrick dils à
l'heure du crime
j'ai vu monsieur d'y venir avec un sac
sur le dos à ce moment là qu'est ce qui
s'est passé bah lui la villa il est
rentré chez lui c'est à dire que vous
êtes en train de dire qu'à aucun moment
il ne s'est dirigé vers les enfants si
jamais jamais jamais les déclarations
troublantes mais bien tardive alors que
la cour de révision doit statuer dans
deux jours sur le cas patrick dils une
décision d'autant plus délicate que les
magistrats ne sont pas en possession de
ces derniers témoignages